four championships in eight years
and many Feelin is a dynasty and in many
field it might be coming to an end if
they don't accept this one green hits a
three and that gets him on their feet
right away Warriors ball with curry
flips one over two Draymond Green and he
throws a foul green lays it in and one
for Draymond Green the key for the
Lakers getting those baskets after this
crowd gets into it there's Green
football movement Wiggins set him up
easy layup for Draymond Green
Looney with an offensive rebound how
many times have announcers said that in
these 2023 playoffs green goes strong
lays it in over the Bronx
Russell no good
curry pushes green comes open green lays
it in
Draymond Green running with curry cream
goes and green finishes Looney rolls to
the basket dick Curry got two on him
two to shoot gotta go Thompson Draymond
Green
foreign